J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, on fait une pause cette semaine dans la couverture des élections de juin prochain pour aborder un sujet souvent méconnu du grand public, surtout si vous êtes un homme, à savoir les violences obstétricales.
Et pour nous éclairer sur cette question complexe et cruciale, j'ai eu le plaisir de recevoir une experte en la matière, Marie-Hélène Lahaye.
Marie-Hélène est une figure engagée dans la lutte contre les violences obstétricales. Elle est juriste, mais elle est aussi surtout l'autrice du blog Marie Accouche-là, qu'elle a ouvert il y a quelques années déjà.
Et au fil du temps, elle est devenue vraiment une référence incontournable dans les médias pour celles et ceux qui cherchent à mieux comprendre et dénoncer les violences subies par les femmes lors des accouchements, mais pas seulement.
On a par exemple aussi parlé des problématiques liées au consentement, au chantage que doivent subir certaines patientes.
Et on a abordé aussi la question de la confraternité médicale, qui est souvent utilisée pour étouffer ou minimiser les fautes des médecins.
Et enfin, on a aussi abordé la question des fausses couches.
Je vous rassure, c'est pas un épisode qui est particulièrement violent, particulièrement trash à écouter, mais forcément, si vous avez été concerné par ce genre de problème par le passé, ce sera
peut-être, j'imagine, un peu plus dur à écouter.
Sur ce, je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Marie-Hélène Lahaye. Bonjour Marie-Hélène.
Bonjour.
Marie-Hélène, donc vous êtes juriste, autrice du blog Marie Accouche-là et du livre Accouchement : La femme mérite mieux, sorti en 2018 chez Michalon.
On va parler du coup ensemble de violences obstétricales puisque c'est un petit peu votre spécialisation, le sujet, la thématique principale abordée sur votre blog.
Alors plein de questions. Déjà, simplement, je vais vous demander qu'est-ce qui vous a amené en fait à vous intéresser à cette question-là en particulier et à en faire un blog ?
Alors, ben le point de départ était mon accouchement en 2012. J'ai eu la chance d'avoir un accouchement respecté. En fait, en 2012, j'étais, je n'étais pas du tout intéressée par les questions d'accouchement.
Pour moi, à l'époque, c'était : oui, la médecine sauve les vies, la péridurale, ça permet de ne pas avoir de douleur.
Et enfin, voilà, j'étais totalement à côté du sujet principal. Et moi-même, j'étais à l'époque fortement engagée en politique.
Enfin, je le suis toujours hein, mais je, voilà, je travaillais pour, dans les cabinets ministériels et sur des questions d'environnement.
Et puis voilà, je me suis retrouvée enceinte et en quelques mois, j'ai remis en question toutes mes croyances initiales qui étaient en fait les croyances qu'on a dans la société hein, sur le côté-
Après l'accouchement là ?
Avant, avant. Donc en quelques mois, j'ai eu la chance vraiment de rencontrer des sages-femmes qui m'ont ouvert les yeux et qui m'ont permis, suite à ce processus de remise en question très rapide de plein de choses,
d'accoucher de façon respectée.
Donc moi, j'ai accouché à l'époque dans, enfin, ce qu'on appelle un plateau technique. Donc c'était j'étais avec ma sage-femme et mon compagnon et voilà rien que, rien que nous trois, dans un hôpital, mais qui...
Enfin, c'était vraiment quelque part privatisé rien que pour nous quoi.
Et c'est là où j'ai découvert ce que c'était un accouchement hein, ce que c'était ces sensations extrêmes, ce que c'était cette expérience extrême, ce,
à la fois une espèce de puissance incroyable qu'on croit ne pas avoir quand on est une femme, qu'on découvre et en même temps une forme de vulnérabilité qui fait que ben on comprend à ce moment-là à quel point,
cet événement extrême, ces sensations extrêmes peuvent être perturbées par des gens qui rentreraient dans la pièce, qui mettraient des piqûres, qui feraient des actes médicaux, qui commenceraient à parler.
Enfin voilà, ce qui se passe dans un accouchement normal, on va dire.
On va en parler, oui.
Et donc voilà, tout se passerait bien. Je comprends ce que c'est un accouchement. Et un an plus tard, suite à une série de discussions, notamment avec Patrick Dupriez, qui était à l'époque président des Écolos,
ben voilà, j'arrive à me poser la question du lien entre l'accouchement et le féminisme.
Parce que jusque-là, en fait, il n'y avait pas spécialement eu de questionnement, aussi paradoxal que ça puisse paraître.
Et, et à la limite, c'est même une partie du combat féministe qui visait à un petit peu se dissocier de l'obligation d'accoucher, l'obligation de la maternité, etc.
Oui, voilà. En fait, c'était ça. C'était exactement ça. Donc la fameuse deuxième vague féministe des années 70 hein, qui était
vraiment orientée droit de ne pas avoir d'enfant, le droit à la contraception, le droit à l'avortement, ce qui est très bien, ce qui est évidemment fondamental.
Ce qui a fait que du coup, le sujet des violences obstétricales a peut-être été un petit peu-
Voilà, exactement. Donc, puisque à ce moment-là, le sujet, c'était d'avoir le droit de ne pas avoir d'enfant.
Il a fallu attendre une génération de féministes de plus pour se dire : Bon ok, on a aussi le droit d'avoir des enfants et d'être bien traité quand on accouche, pour faire simple.
Et c'est comme ça que je me suis
intéressée à cette question. Et puis, enfin, un peu de façon compulsive, en posant plein de questions, en essayant de comprendre ce qu'il y avait, enfin surtout ce que les féministes avaient dit
et en découvrant qu'elles n'avaient à peu près rien dit.
Et c'est comme ça que j'ai eu l'idée, au départ d'ouvrir ce blog que je pensais totalement confidentiel, parce que c'était vraiment un sujet de niche, le féminisme, l'accouchement, enfin un petit truc qui n'intéresse que les,
que les passionnés de féministes.
C'était en 2012, 2013 à ce moment-là. Et puis voilà, j'ai eu la surprise de voir que mes billets de blog étaient partagés des milliers de fois.
J'ai reçu des milliers de témoignages de femmes qui m'ont fait prendre conscience d'une réalité encore pire que ce que je n'imaginais.
Hein, c'était pas juste un petit peu d'inconfort, mais c'était vraiment des scènes de torture. Et ça m'a encouragé à continuer à comprendre ce qui se passait et à développer toute ma pensée autour de ce sujet-là.
On reparlera peut-être plus tard des éventuelles évolutions qu'on a pu constater, faire le constat de si les choses ont empiré ou si les choses vont mieux depuis.
Mais on va peut-être reposer les bases. Comment est-ce que vous définiriez les violences obstétricales ?
Alors, y a pas de définition officielle. Donc il y a l'OMS qui parle de bienveillance pendant l'accouchement, d'expérience positive pendant l'accouchement.
On a le Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes en France qui aussi a émis un rapport sur ce sujet-là. On a le Conseil de l'Europe qui a une recommandation.
Donc voilà, il y a plein de choses qui existent. Mais si je devais en revenir à la base, donc moi, j'avais réfléchi à une définition en tant que juriste qui est que c'est...
une violence obstétricale, c'est tout comportement, acte, omission ou abstention commis par le personnel de santé sur une femme qui accouche, qui n'a pas reçu le consentement libre et éclairé et qui n'a pas de justification médicale.
En gros, c'est ça. Donc il y a vraiment quatre grandes dimensions. C'est un acte ou une absence d'acte, par exemple une non-prise en compte de la douleur.
Le personnel soignant, ça peut être tout le monde, pas uniquement les gynécologues, mais les sages-femmes, les anesthésistes, les médecins, les infirmières, les aides-soignantes.
Enfin, un petit peu toutes les personnes qui peuvent, à un moment donné, interagir avec la femme. Alors, la question du consentement, qui est vraiment une question centrale, qui a vraiment émergé en 2016
par rapport à une action qu'on a menée sur les touchers vaginaux sur patientes endormies au bloc opératoire, qui a vraiment mis le consentement au cœur.
C'était juste avant MeToo, donc c'est vraiment dans les prémices du mouvement MeToo qu'on a inscrit le consentement.
Et puis la question de la nécessité médicale, qui est aussi un grand point qui, ben qui, 'fin qui est simplement le reflet, ben de la science, hein, de qu'est-ce que les recommandations scientifiques disent.
Et pour faire simple, en fait, dans 90 % des cas, les femmes accouchent sans aide médicale. Donc elles n'en ont pas besoin.
Il y a, si on prend les chiffres, sur cent accouchements, il y en a nonante qui se passent très bien, 10 % où il y a
un souci, principalement avec le bébé, où il faut agir pour sauver le bébé, ce qui correspond d'ailleurs aux 10 % de césariennes recommandées par l'OMS.
Et avant, il y avait environ moins d'1 % de femmes qui mouraient. Donc là, il y a effectivement une nécessité médicale pour agir par rapport à ce risque de mortalité.
Ben donc ça veut dire que dans l'écrasante majorité des cas, en fait, les femmes peuvent accoucher sans intervention médicale.
Et c'est là où l'importance de, où l'intérêt de la science et l'intérêt du geste médical peut être questionné.
On va reparler de cette notion d'accoucher en solo.
Donc, dans tout ce qui a été évoqué,
la notion de consentement, la notion d'acte ou d'absence d'acte,
pour qu'il puisse y avoir intervention, pour qu'il puisse y avoir sanction ou renforcement de règles, il faudrait presque une surveillance au sein du bloc opératoire pour vérifier que
le médecin, la sage-femme, l'anesthésiste, tout le monde se comporte correctement.
Or, ce n'est pas le cas.
Oui, ben ça pose... 'fin, mettre un, je sais pas, policier dans la salle d'accouchement, c'est un petit peu compliqué, évidemment.
Et lui n'étant pas formé au sujet, donc ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens.
Pas forcément mieux.
Donc voilà, c'est peut-être pas la meilleure idée à mettre en place tout de suite. Mais donc quand on décortique les choses, on se rend compte de quoi ?
Que d'abord, le vrai souci, c'est d'abord les croyances. Les croyances, y compris chez les médecins, hein. Donc c'est vraiment cette croyance que les femmes ne sont pas capables d'accoucher par elles-mêmes,
que le bassin des femmes est mal foutu, que, 'fin la tête du bébé est trop grosse par rapport au bassin.
'Fin il y a vraiment une obsession aussi par rapport au bassin des femmes. Donc ça, c'est assez étonnant. Que le corps des femmes ne fonctionne pas correctement.
'Fin voilà, il y a plein de croyances autour de ça
qu'il faut d'abord arriver à déconstruire, y compris chez les médecins, parce que ça questionne aussi finalement ce qu'ils auront eux-mêmes appris et ce qu'ils ont eux-mêmes reçu de transmission en transmission.
Donc, il y a vraiment au sein des universitaires, encore aujourd'hui, cette notion de : le corps des femmes est fondamentalement défectueux, ne fonctionne pas comme il faut.
Ben oui, en fait. Donc le Sénat, on va peut-être en parler un peu plus tard, mais le Sénat a remis un rapport en janvier sur les violences obstétricales.
Et quand on lit les experts qui ont été interrogés en vue d'obtenir ce rapport, il y a notamment des gynécologues qui parlent au nom des gynécologues.
Et il y a tout un paragraphe qui explique que le bassin des femmes ne fonctionne pas et n'est pas apte à accoucher. Donc, on en est là encore aujourd'hui,
en 2024, alors même qu'il y a des travaux, y compris des travaux de paléontologues qui ont été passer leur temps à mesurer tous les bassins des femmes et qui--
et dont la conclusion est assez claire, c'est que les femmes ont un corps qui fonctionne bien et qu'elles sont capables d'accoucher.
Voilà, il n'y a pas un problème de bassin.
Oui.
Donc ça, c'est... voilà.
Donc vous disiez dans 90 % des cas, l'expérience est relativement positive.
Oui.
Mais même dans ces 90 %, on constate que l'obstétricien, l'obstétricienne, ou plutôt les hommes, plutôt les obstétriciens du coup-
Pas nécessairement.
Pas nécessairement, OK.
Vont avoir en eux, en elles ces idées-là, ces idées du bassin fondamentalement défectueux.
Voilà, voilà, c'est ça. C'est d'office, il faut intervenir. C'est vraiment ce principe de : on met les femmes sur le dos, on les met sous péridurale, elles ne bougent plus.
Et alors, il y a donc non seulement ces croyances qui sont là, mais aussi les protocoles. Donc, sur base de ces croyances, les hôpitaux ont établi des protocoles très précis sur les modalités d'accouchement.
Et ces protocoles, c'est pas uniquement, 'fin, des protocoles sont utiles. Donc voilà, une situation d'urgence, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Voilà, ça, c'est à ce moment-là, on sort le protocole et c'est très bien. Mais qu'est-ce qu'on constate ? C'est que quand on regarde de près comment fonctionne une maternité, ça fonctionne comme une usine à la chaîne.
Donc c'est, les femmes sont couchées chacune dans leur box et sont reliées à des fils, à une tour de contrôle, hein, donc une pièce qui contrôle tous les paramètres.
Le rôle des sages-femmes, c'est de courir entre plusieurs femmes qui accouchent en même temps et d'ajuster les paramètres.
Donc, on augmente un petit peu la perfusion d'ocytocine pour accélérer les contractions. Si on voit qu'elle est sur le point d'accoucher et que le médecin est justement libre à ce moment-là.
L'autre, on va un petit peu la ralentir pour que les deux accouchements se fassent pas simultanément. Et donc pour mettre en place ce système d'accouchement à la chaîne, en fait, on a tout à fait repris le système fordiste de l'accouchement.
Donc, comme Ford avait mis en place début du XXᵉ siècle son usine pour construire des voitures à la chaîne. Alors, le fordisme repose sur quoi ?
Il repose sur deux principes : la standardisation
des objets à produire à la chaîne et la standardisation des gestes. Et c'est exactement ça qu'on a imposé aux femmes, c'est standardiser le corps des femmes pour qu'elles accouchent toutes de la même façon
et notamment des durées.
Par exemple, la durée d'ouverture du col de l'utérus doit être d'un centimètre par heure, par exemple. Voilà.
Et donc si c'est pas un centimètre par heure, hop, on agit, on augmente, on ralentit pour que ça tombe bien dans les clous.
C'est très carré, quoi. C'est très-
Oui, voilà. Et-
Pas forcément respectueux de la façon dont un corps fonctionne, quoi.
Voilà, exactement. Et donc on va dire : Bon à la limite, à la limite, on pourrait penser que... Sauf que mettre comme ça, injecter de l'ocytocine de synthèse qui est l'hormone qui permet de favoriser les contractions,
produit plus de risques d'hémorragie.
Et c'est comme ça, par exemple, qu'on constate qu'il y a plus d'hémorragies dans les hôpitaux qu'à la maison, puisqu'il y a eu cette ocytocine.
Et puis après coup, les médecins vont dire : Oui, mais regardez, il y a un risque d'hémorragie, donc l'accouchement est dangereux, donc elles doivent accoucher à l'hôpital, donc il faut agir.
Et donc cette espèce de cascade d'actes médicaux qui entraînent d'autres actes médicaux, s'est produit dans les hôpitaux.
Et donc il y a une vision quelque part, à la fois un fonctionnement des maternités qui renforce cette vision de l'accouchement dangereux
dont sont imprégnés les médecins et qui finalement, alimente d'office cette façon de penser, de fonctionner.
Et donc vous défendez l'idée que finalement, un accouchement de base n'est pas spécialement dangereux et qu'on n'a pas besoin de toutes ces sécurités, tous ces inconforts et ces notions de un centimètre par heure, etc.
Voilà.
Tout ça n'est pas nécessaire, selon vous.
Ben non, au contraire, c'est même contre-productif. Donc idéalement, il faut partir du principe que, bon voilà, nous, en plus, on a la capacité aujourd'hui de pouvoir anticiper une grossesse à risque.
On a des données scientifiques qui montrent que, par exemple, des jumeaux, c'est plus dangereux que un premier accouchement.
Il y a un peu plus de risques qu'un deuxième accouchement, surtout si le premier s'est bien passé, dans le cas du deuxième.
Il y a des femmes, voilà, qui présentent certaines pathologies qui sont plus à risque que d'autres. Et on sait que quand le,
par exemple, je rentre dans des questions techniques, mais quand le placenta est fixé sur l'ouverture du col de l'utérus, on peut le détecter par échographie et on sait que là, il y a un risque supplémentaire.
Donc, il y a plein de choses comme ça qu'on peut détecter et anticiper des situations plus à risque. Et là, effectivement, la médecine a tout son rôle pour intervenir en cas de risque.
Mais d'un autre côté, toutes les femmes qui ne sont pas à risque, laissons-les accoucher comme elles souhaitent. Donc, si elles préfèrent accoucher seules avec leur sage-femme, si elles préfèrent ne pas médicaliser leur accouchement, très bien.
Et en cas de problème, si jamais malgré tout, il y a un problème, parce qu'il y a toujours un petit risque, il peut toujours se passer quelque chose,
à ce moment-là, on a la chance d'avoir des hôpitaux autour de nous et on organise un transfert de la femme vers l'hôpital, voilà, pour une intervention.
'Fin, ça se passe même mieux qu'avant à ce niveau-là, mais ce serait une utilisation raisonnée de la médecine et pas une espèce de sur-médicalisation inutile, imposée à toutes les femmes.
Je présume que du coup, ça, ça a pas été votre expérience ? Pas à l'hôpital, du coup. L'accouchement.
Moi, mon accouchement, c'était en plateau technique dans un hôpital, mais comme à la maison, dans un hôpital, à ce moment-là.
Vous pouvez m'expliquer un petit peu ? Comme à la maison, mais dans un hôpital ?
Oui, en fait, donc ben c'est en fait ce qu'on appelle-
C'est privatisé, c'est ce que vous dites.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc c'est la salle, ce qui s'appelle la salle nature. Donc c'est un endroit où c'est pas juste une salle d'accouchement, c'est...
Voilà, il y a des matelas, des ballons, une petite décoration. 'Fin, à la limite, on s'en fiche qu'on accouche, on n'est pas tellement intéressé par tout ça.
Mais surtout, c'est le fait d'être uniquement avec ma sage-femme qui m'a permis d'accoucher dans la position que je voulais, de bouger comme je voulais, de me soutenir, de m'encourager.
Elle était juste là pour moi. Elle devait pas partir toutes les heures, aller s'occuper d'autres femmes en parallèle. Il y avait pas des gens qui rentraient, qui sortaient à tout bout de champ dans la salle.
Il y avait pas de lumières vives, de piqûres, de fils qui me raccordaient où je devais pas bouger parce que sinon, je risquais de modifier les capteurs.
Ça a duré combien de temps ?
Oh ben ça a duré quelques heures, hein. Je suis arrivée là vers, je crois que ça a commencé vers 6 h, je dois accoucher vers minuit, donc c'est allé assez vite en termes de contractions.
Voilà, ça allait bien parce que j'étais moi-même en confiance et j'étais bien entourée. Et ça, ça joue énormément.
Évidemment, si on se sent à l'aise, si on se sent bien, ça favorise l'accouchement plutôt que d'être en état de stress et...
C'est le genre d'offre que peu d'hôpitaux proposent, j'imagine.
Alors à l'époque, ben il y avait juste Sainte-Élisabeth qui le faisait, mais je pense qu'il ne le fait plus. Puis il y a Erasme qui a ouvert le 'fin, pour Bruxelles, hein, qui a ouvert le cocon,
qui a fait donc là vraiment un gîte de naissance.
C'est encore même plus élaboré que simplement une salle qu'on privatise.
Et puis il y a eu un accord tout récemment, porté par le ministre Alain Maron, qui a aussi la santé dans ses compétences, qui oblige, 'fin, maintenant,
dans les prochains mois, tous les hôpitaux bruxellois à proposer justement ce principe de privatisation d'une salle d'accouchement où les femmes pourraient venir avec leur sage-femme.
Donc voilà, on voit que ça rentre tout doucement dans,
dans les mentalités et que ça peut,
effectivement ouvrir une alternative pour les femmes qui n'ont pas spécialement envie d'accoucher chez elles pour un tas de raisons, mais qui veulent pas non plus accoucher de façon classique, médicalisée dans les hôpitaux,
mais qui préfèrent être accompagnées par une sage-femme qu'elles connaissent et faire les choses, voilà, à leur rythme, dans un environnement
à leurs yeux sécurisé.
Mh. Donc on a surtout parlé des interventions douloureuses ou des absences d'intervention en cas de douleur, voilà.
Une autre forme de violence, est-ce que ça peut se constater, des violences, disons, verbales, des comportements, des mots qui sont prononcés, des choses comme ça ?
Est-ce que ça s'observe aussi ?
Oui, alors il y a toute une panoplie de violences, hein, malheureusement. Alors oui, effectivement, il y a les paroles.
Là, ça renvoie à quelque chose de très sexiste et très dans la représentation de ce que c'est une femme qui accouche, hein.
Donc, une femme qui accouche, c'est quoi ? Elle devient un petit peu animale comme ça, elle se met à hurler.
C'est très physique, en fait, on lâche prise et puis le corps fonctionne tout seul, mais ça peut aussi donner des sensations extrêmes, y compris les cris.
Mais les cris sont autorisés chez les hommes et pas chez les femmes. Vous voyez les guerriers qui foncent à l'attaque, ils crient.
On va dire : Mais c'est pas parce qu'ils ont mal, c'est juste parce qu'ils crient pour se donner de la force, du courage.
C'est juste ça. Une femme qui fait ça, non. Tout de suite, la représentation, on ne peut pas. Les femmes, on n'admet pas qu'elles se comportent comme ça.
Et donc, il y a tout un jeu de domination qui se met en place où, voilà, l'entourage des femmes considère inapproprié qu'elles se comportent de cette façon-là parce qu'elles doivent être bien silencieuses, gentilles, douces.
Vous voyez, toutes les représentations qu'on peut avoir en termes de stéréotypes de genre. Et ça-
Même pour les obstétriciens, obstétriciennes qui ont été confrontés à ça deux cents fois en une année.
Ah oui. C'est vraiment quelque chose à déconstruire. C'est qu'une femme peut hurler et peut insulter le gynécologue.
Ça fait partie du processus. Et un gynécologue va tout faire pour calmer cette femme parce qu'il va trouver ça inadmissible.
Y compris crier dessus, y compris humilier avec des paroles de type : « Oui, de toute façon, vous m'appeliez pas quand vous le faisiez, cet enfant ».
Vous voyez, ce genre d'attitudes méprisantes ou humiliantes qui n'ont absolument pas leur place à ce moment-là. Il y en a certains qui ont giflé des femmes.
Il y a plein de témoignages de femmes qui ont reçu des coups et des gifles d'un gynécologue qui supportait pas que cette femme crie.
Donc là, on est plutôt dans les dix pour cent de cas vraiment violents ou négatifs. Dans nonante pour cent des cas, c'est absent. On est d'accord ?
Alors, il y a pas de chi-- enfin, si. On a--
La Plateforme pour une naissance respectée a fait une étude, donc juste après le COVID, la plateforme a interrogé quatre mille femmes en Belgique francophone sur les conditions de leur accouchement en deux mille
dix-neuf et deux mille vingt, donc l'année du COVID et l'année précédente du COVID, pour pouvoir comparer les deux données.
Les résultats montrent qu'il y a une femme sur cinq en moyenne qui a subi des violences obstétricales.
D'accord.
Parmi lesquelles des violences verbales. Quand les femmes ont un niveau socioéconomique un peu plus défavorisé, donc en gros, elles n'ont pas fait d'études supérieures, voilà, le chiffre monte.
On est à une femme sur quatre, donc vingt-cinq pour cent des femmes.
Donc un petit peu de mépris de classe qui se rajoute.
Voilà, mépris de classe. Voilà, elles-mêmes n'ont peut-être pas nécessairement les ressources. Peut-être qu'elles parlent aussi différemment.
Enfin voilà, il y a plein de choses qui peuvent jouer. Quand une femme a une couleur de peau qui entraîne des discriminations, le niveau de violence obstétricale monte encore.
C'est une femme sur trois, trente-trois pour cent des femmes.
Et si on combine les deux ?
Alors si on combine, alors là, on n'a pas été jusqu'au bout pour combiner, mais enfin, on voit quand même qu'il y a des choses qui s'ajoutent.
Et voilà. Et parmi les six catégories de violences qui ont été identifiées, il y a les violences verbales. Donc ce n'est pas une toute petite minorité de femmes qui seraient mal tombées sur un gynécologue qui, franchement, n'aurait pas sa place.
Il y a quelque chose de vraiment systémique
dans le fait de parler comme ça aux femmes. Et par contraste, quand on parle avec des sages-femmes qui se sont vraiment spécialisées en naissances respectées, donc qui ont vraiment été étudier en profondeur
les conditions idéales d'accouchement, de quoi les femmes ont besoin, quel est l'environnement nécessaire
pour qu'elles se sentent bien, qu'est-ce qui favorise l'accouchement.
Enfin, il y a des travaux qui ont vraiment porté là-dessus. On se rend compte que notamment, il faut qu'elles soient dans le silence,
qu'on leur chuchote à l'oreille éventuellement un petit mot, mais surtout pas leur parler fort parce que ça, ça les déconnecte un petit peu
de la situation.
Accepter qu'elles crient, voilà, ça fait partie du job d'accepter d'être pendant des heures avec une femme qui crie à côté de soi.
C'est comme ça, ça fait partie de la profession. Et d'ailleurs, elles-mêmes reconnaissent sur base de l'attitude de la femme et parfois même sur la nature des cris, s'il y a un problème ou si c'est normal.
Donc elles ont elles-mêmes cette capacité de comprendre les choses et d'analyser les choses comme ça. Donc c'est très particulier, c'est très différent de la représentation qu'on a, nous,
de l'accouchement dans les hôpitaux où on veut juste que les femmes soient couchées, silencieuses.
On leur met la péridurale, elles sentent rien, elles se taisent, surtout, elles se taisent. Et voilà, elles accouchent quand le médecin veut qu'elles accouchent.
Alors là, je vais faire une remarque. Je spécule complètement, mais c'est un peu basé sur mon expérience avec plutôt les urgences.
J'ai un petit peu l'impression que les médecins, à force de voir des gens qui crient, qui souffrent, qui sont, voilà, dans une situation d'urgence, développent un petit peu...
Mais là, comme je disais, je spécule complètement. C'est une question que je me pose. Ils essayent de réduire un petit peu leur niveau d'empathie et ça essaye un petit peu de
prendre du recul et d'éviter de trop, ouais, se mettre à la place de la personne qui crie.
Finalement, il y a une espèce de distance, de déshumanisation presque qui s'installe. Est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu de ça ?
Alors, il faut une distance. Donc moi, je demande pas aux médecins d'être complètement en empathie avec la femme qui accouche, mais il y a une attitude à avoir.
Oui.
Et c'est ça la différence. Donc, je demande pas aux médecins de ressentir les contractions en même temps.
Voilà, tout à fait. Puis qu'il y ait une certaine distance, qu'il y ait une capacité, y compris quand ça se passe mal. Voilà, il y a quand même des situations où il y a bébé qui meurt.
Enfin, ça arrive hein. Donc il faut malgré tout que les professionnels restent professionnels. Il y ait cette capacité de mettre une certaine distance.
Mais ça n'empêche pas que par ailleurs, il y ait une capacité à reconnaître qu'un accouchement, c'est très particulier. Pour moi, ce qui se passe dans un accouchement, c'est vraiment de la puissance.
Donc, on est vraiment dans le cri du guerrier et pas dans le cri de la personne qu'on torture. Donc, il y a quand même cette notion-là qu'il faut avoir en tête.
Donc, on parlait des différents sous-groupes de femmes qui peuvent être plus ou moins sujettes à ces violences. Inversement, si on regarde les médecins, est-ce qu'il y a des endroits, des cliniques, des universités...
Est-ce qu'on peut voir des sous-groupes de médecins, donc de gynécologues, obstétriciens, obstétriciennes, chez qui on observe davantage de comportements problématiques ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est vraiment réparti pareil partout ?
Alors oui, il y a-- enfin, il y a les deux. Donc il y a à la fois...
Alors c'est assez étonnant, parce que quand moi, j'ai commencé à écrire mon blog, je me suis retrouvée face à une espèce de bloc monolithique de médecins qui s'opposaient à moi.
Voilà. Bon, j'ai continué tranquillement.
Pardon. Il y a très fort aussi ce truc de la solidarité de la blouse blanche.
Voilà.
Et surtout, on ne critique pas les autres confrères.
Oui.
Et bon, d'accord, il a fait une bêtise, mais voilà, il l'a pas fait exprès. C'est un jeune médecin, il a seulement quarante-sept ans. Voilà.
Voilà,
exactement. Exactement, oui. C'est le principe de confraternité, justement. Voilà, on est vraiment là-dedans. Et donc moi, j'étais face à un bloc monolithique de médecins qui étaient dans le déni, qui voulaient pas entendre quoi que ce soit.
Et la médecine sauve des vies. Et vous, vous voulez la mort des femmes et des bébés. Enfin, c'était vraiment un discours, voilà, comme ça.
Et puis au fil du temps, plus j'écrivais, plus j'étais présente dans les médias, j'avais des médecins, des femmes, des hommes, les deux d'ailleurs,
qui m'ont contactée, qui m'ont dit : Je voudrais vraiment vous rencontrer, mais je voudrais pas que ça se sache.
Est-ce qu'on peut se rencontrer à l'arrière d'un café, vraiment en secret, voyez le-
Avec un masque, ouais.
Voilà. Je dis : Oui, OK, d'accord, allons-y. Et là, vraiment, enfin vraiment, c'est l'impression d'être face, je sais pas...
Qui ont commencé à me raconter : Oui, mais vous avez raison, vous savez, parce que moi-
Un lanceur d'alerte quoi.
Voilà,
ce que j'ai vu des trucs. Ils ont commencé à me raconter l'expérience qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes dans les maternités, qui les scandalisaient, mais ils étaient coincés par le principe de confraternité et ne pouvaient rien faire.
Mmh.
Et donc ils m'encourageaient à continuer en me profilant des informations en off et tout ça sur ce fonctionnement.
Donc c'était très intéressant de voir que finalement, il y en a qui bougent, c'est pas ce bloc monolithique tel qu'on pourrait le penser.
Et qu'il y a vraiment une chape de plomb qui-
Il y a vraiment une chape de plomb. Et voilà. Et eux-mêmes, c'est compliqué pour eux de vouloir-- et le vivent très mal d'ailleurs, souvent, hein, puisqu'ils veulent bien faire et puis se retrouvent dans un environnement très compliqué
où ils sont critiqués.
Et puis j'ai aussi con-- donc petit à petit, il y a eu ça. Puis j'ai aussi constaté qu'il y avait des médecins qui essayaient de changer des choses, parfois des chefs de service même, qui essaient d'impulser
d'autres pratiques dans leur maternité.
Et c'était compliqué pour eux, parce que de nouveau, c'était tellement en rupture par rapport à ce qu'ils avaient appris, par rapport aux normes de la profession, que pour eux, ils étaient vite très isolés, parfois très vite critiqués.
Et malheureusement, beaucoup d'entre eux ont fini par quitter l'hôpital et se lancer uniquement en libéral pour faire une activité en parallèle parce que c'était trop compliqué pour eux.
Ils avaient trop de pression à vouloir changer des choses. Donc c'est ça que je constate hein, c'est qu'il y a
à la fois des choses qui peuvent vraiment changer l'ambiance d'une maternité à l'initiative d'un ou une chef de service qui ait une autre vision et qui veut autre chose.
Et très vite, ça peut être détricoté parce qu'il y a une nouvelle personne qui arrive et tout ce qui était engrangé, ben change.
Il y a ça. Et puis il y a certains hôpitaux qui se sont un petit peu, ben dès le départ, un peu profilés sur des questions plus respectueuses et des façons plus respectueuses de prendre en charge les patientes.
C'est un peu le cas à Saint-Pierre, hein, ici à Bruxelles, pour donner un exemple, où ils ont vraiment une culture d'ouverture, ben notamment en acceptant des migrantes, en acceptant vraiment un côté très multiculturel.
Et donc à partir du moment où on accepte, voilà, toutes les façons d'accoucher, il y a aussi cette notion de respect qui émerge aussi et qui permet de pratiquer des accouchements de façon très variée.
Voilà un petit peu de réponses comme ça. Et d'un autre côté, ce qu'on connaît aussi, c'est des gynécologues qui sont connus pour être des bouchers.
Ça, c'est clair. Il y a même eu des sages-femmes, des étudiants de sages-femmes qui ont à un moment donné lancé l'alerte en disant qu'elles ne veulent plus aller dans tel hôpital parce que le chef de service est absolument horrible.
Il traumatise toutes les femmes, il traumatise toutes les sages-femmes. Elles sortent de là complètement effondrées de ce qu'elles ont vu et elles ne veulent même plus y aller.
Tellement que voilà, le chef de service, c'est le boucher, tout le monde le sait, mais malgré tout, il reste là parce qu'il est le chef de service et...
Et voilà. Donc oui, il y a un peu tout et moi, j'espère, enfin, je suis déjà soutenue par une partie des gynécos qui sont
plus modernes, plus lucides, plus respectueux et qui veulent d'autres pratiques, mais ça reste encore un petit peu tendu au sein même de la profession. Voilà, pour eux.
Et je pense qu'on n'a pas le droit en fait de faire une liste de gynécologues validés, pour dire : Ceux-là sont bien, ceux-là, ils sont pas bien.
On n'a pas le droit de faire ça, je pense. Si ?
Oh si, on a le droit de tout faire hein. Enfin, pas les gynécologues entre eux, mais il y a des initiatives de femmes qui font des espèces de-- déjà, enfin.
Une white list, on peut faire ça ?
On pourrait, oui, oui, ça existe. Et en fait, c'est jamais qu'une pratique qui se pratiquait depuis toujours.
Les femmes se refilaient des noms sous le manteau, de gynécos qui pratiquaient des avortements quand c'était pas légal, de gynécologues plus agréables que d'autres.
Enfin, c'était déjà des pratiques que les femmes avaient entre elles. Sauf que là, avec Internet, on permet finalement plus de facilité dans l'échange des noms.
Ouais, c'est une bonne chose. Donc vous donniez l'exemple, par exemple, de ce chef de service particulièrement, voilà, un boucher, vous disiez.
Mmh.
Et donc pour revenir là à ma question, est-ce qu'on observe par exemple, je sais pas moi, que
il y a quelque chose de générationnel ou qu'il y a quelque chose de culturel, de certaines universités ou de certains milieux ou de certaines classes sociales ou des choses comme ça ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est vraiment réparti de façon équilibrée un peu ?
Oh alors, il y a pas de statistiques hein. Donc là, on n'a pas vraiment fait une statistique sur l'origine des médecins, l'origine socio-économique des médecins et est-ce que selon leur origine socio-économique, ils sont
plus respectueux que d'autres ?
Concernant, on n'a pas les données. Est-ce qu'il y a une donnée générationnelle ? Peut-être,
mais je dirais limitée. Donc effectivement, il y a des médecins plus âgés qui ont toujours fait comme ça, qui continuent à faire comme ça, qui se remettent pas en question et qui, voilà.
Il y en a même certains qui quittent la profession parce que, et ce qui est aussi, il faut aussi tenir compte du fait qu'il y a un changement chez les femmes.
Donc les femmes ne sont plus les mêmes qu'il y a dix ans. Aujourd'hui, les femmes posent des questions, elles sont informées, elles vont sur Internet, elles comprennent
ce qui se joue, elles découvrent le concept de violence obstétricale, elles se posent des questions.
Et la première chose qu'elles font quand elles vont chez le gynécologue, c'est poser plein de questions.
Et des gynécologues qui rient en disant : Ben moi, j'ai l'impression de repasser mes examens devant chaque patiente parce qu'elles sont tellement là à poser des questions.
Chose qui n'arrivait absolument pas il y a dix ans où les femmes considéraient que les gynécologues savaient tout et elles étaient bêtes et elles ne posaient pas de questions.
Et de toute façon, c'était très mal venu d'aller interroger le gynécologue.
Donc il y a ça. Alors, il y a des gynécologues qui se prennent au jeu, qui bon voilà, ça fait partie de la nouvelle patientèle et d'autres qui supportent pas et qui quittent la profession.
Mmh.
Il y a ça qu'on peut constater.
Qui aiment pas être remis en question.
Voilà. Et supportent même plus d'être tout le temps, elles n'ont plus confiance. Et puis peut-être qu'eux-mêmes ne savent pas répondre et se retrouvent un peu en porte-à-faux avec, voilà.
Et alors, est-ce qu'il y a une différence au niveau de l'origine des universités ? C'est pas évident. C'est pas évident. Il y a un-
Je posais cette question-là précisément parce que je sais que dans le cadre, par exemple, des questions liées aux IVG ou aux vasectomies,
ben je veux le dire ouvertement, par exemple, les cliniques universitaires Saint-Luc, catholiques, liées à l'UCL, on peut avoir des comportements, mais très très rétrogrades et des réponses...
Voilà, je vais le dire très directement hein, parce que je sais qu'elle en parle, elle est à l'aise avec le fait qu'on en parle publiquement.
Il y a une amie, la compagne d'un ami qui a eu un jour une grossesse extra-utérine. Et donc elle a dû aller aux urgences à Saint-Luc et s'est retrouvée à donc devoir demander une intervention volontaire de grossesse.
Et comme elle avait l'air très jeune alors qu'elle était mariée, qu'elle avait passé trente ans, mais elle avait l'air très jeune, il y avait cette présomption dans le regard des médecins de
encore une ado irresponsable qui a fait n'importe quoi et vraiment un comportement très paternaliste et très méprisant et tout ça.
Inversement, voilà, un homme qui demande une vasectomie, on peut juste la lui refuser à Saint-Luc alors que dans une autre clinique, on va dire : bah oui, bien sûr, signez ici, voilà, y a pas de souci.
Donc voilà, je pose cette question parce que je sais que sur ces questions-là, par exemple, j'ai été amené à entendre et à observer des comportements très différents en fonction des hôpitaux.
Oui, alors sur effectivement ces questions d'IVG, de contraception, de stérilisation, d'interruption de grossesse, parfois même d'interruption tardive de grossesse, 'fin,
on interrompt la grossesse parce que le fœtus est handicapé, par exemple.
Voilà, y a plein de questions éthiques hein qui peuvent à un moment donné surgir en cas de grossesse et ou liées à la contraception.
C'est sûr que les hôpitaux laïcs sont souvent plus ouverts. Ça, faut pas se cacher, il y a une autre philosophie derrière et...
Au niveau des accouchements, on ne le sait pas forcément.
Au niveau des accouchements, c'est moins flagrant.
Ok.
C'est moins flagrant. Parfois même des hôpitaux laïcs pour être sur le mode : oui, mais il faut absolument que les femmes prennent une péridurale parce que justement, il faut pas souffrir et que la souffrance, c'est catholique.
Enfin donc parfois, il y a ce côté un peu là aussi. Ça dépend. Vraiment, ça dépend. Donc moi, j'ai pas constaté de différences philosophiques, on va dire, dans le respect de l'accouchement.
C'est pas flagrant. Moi, je dirais que c'est vraiment plutôt
qui est là, qui est chef de service, quelle est la philosophie du chef de service, quelle est l'ambiance générale dans l'hôpital pour déterminer si oui ou non les femmes sont respectées ou pas.
Ok. Donc jusqu'à là, on a surtout parlé de l'accouchement lui-même. Est-ce que les violences obstétricales, les violences, donc voilà, dans le cadre des consultations
avec un ou une gynécologue, ça dépasse le cadre de l'accouchement ou...
voilà, est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses à rajouter ?
Oui, alors donc on parle des violences obstétricales au moment de l'accouchement. Effectivement, il y a un truc que moi, je questionne évidemment sur toute la société, c'est ce contrôle médical
du corps des femmes pendant toute leur vie sexuelle et reproductive.
Et donc, par exemple en France, le Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes a émis un rapport en 2018 sur les violences obstétricales.
Et là, ils ont notamment calculé le fait que les femmes, en moyenne sur leur vie, vont consulter cinquante fois un gynécologue.
Donc cinquante fois sur une vie, alors même que a priori, elles sont pas en mauvaise santé. Donc c'est vraiment une espèce de passage obligé d'aller chez le gynécologue au cours de sa vie.
Ça fait partie, enfin comme chez le dentiste. Donc c'est un peu paradoxal. Pourquoi ? Ben pour demander une contraception, ce qui n'est pas une maladie, pour demander une interruption de grossesse qui n'est pas une maladie, pour se faire
un suivi en cas de fausse couche, ce qui n'est pas une maladie, pour
pour l'accouchement, ce qui n'est pas une maladie.
Et même pour la ménopause, ce n'est pas une maladie non plus. Et pourtant, toutes ces étapes sont considérées comme étant suspectes et devront être contrôlées, vérifiées sur le plan médical.
Et donc, à cette occasion-là, effectivement, il y a toute une série de mécanismes d'abus, de domination, de paternalisme, de jugement qui ont lieu pour les médecins qui se retrouvent ben déjà pas formés.
Enfin voilà, imaginez une jeune fille de seize, dix-sept ans qui débute sa vie sexuelle, qui va demander une contraception, qui se retrouve face à un gynécologue ou une gynécologue qui a quarante, quarante-cinq, cinquante, cinquante-cinq ans
et qui va devoir expliquer à cette personne, qui va lui sembler déjà très vieille de son point de vue, les prémices de sa vie sexuelle et qu'elle a besoin de contraception.
Et il arrive très souvent qu'à cette occasion-là, le gynécologue lui impose un examen gynécologique. Pourquoi ? Pour rien.
Comme ça, sans lui expliquer pourquoi, les tenants, les aboutissants, l'intérêt, le non-intérêt. Et elle qui est un peu prise au piège en se disant : ben soit je l'accepte et j'ai ma contraception, soit j'accepte pas et j'ai pas ma contraception.
Donc il y a vraiment quelque chose de malsain qui se joue dès ce moment-là. Alors même qu'il faut quand même rappeler que l'examen gynécologique n'est pas du tout recommandé avant vingt-cinq ans et puis après, tous les trois ans, tous les cinq ans.
Donc imposer un examen gynécologique à une fille qui a seize, dix-huit ans n'a absolument aucun sens. Il y a aucun intérêt médical.
Et puis d'ailleurs, on peut se poser la question de pourquoi aller chez un spécialiste qui a fait dix ans d'études, douze ans d'études pour se faire prescrire un paquet de pilules quoi.
Enfin, ça n'a de nouveau aucun sens.
Et il y a d'ailleurs eu des demandes à un moment donné, auxquelles j'ai participé, de considérer que la contraception devrait sortir du rôle de gynécologue, devrait peut-être une première contraception obtenue chez le médecin, éventuellement
chez une infirmière ou une sage-femme qui vérifie simplement certains paramètres.
Et après, renouvellement directement à la pharmacie. Pas besoin de repasser tous les six mois, tous les neuf mois, tous les ans chez le médecin juste pour ça.
Ça n'a aucun sens.
Tous les six mois, effectivement, je comprends. Après, il y a aussi la notion de, par exemple, dépistage du cancer du col de l'utérus, faire des frottis, ce genre de choses.
C'est peut-être un peu plus pertinent.
C'est pertinent à partir de, alors à partir de vingt-cinq ans.
Oui.
Pas avant.
Oui, oui, oui.
Et puis tous les trois ans, voire tous les cinq ans quand on fait le dépistage du HPV. Donc ça, c'est tout.
Donc il y a absolument aucun lien. Et puis en plus, c'est le lien. Et c'est ça aussi qui dérange, c'est le lien à faire entre la contraception et le dépistage.
Ça n'a pas de sens. Quand on vient pour une contraception, on vient pour une contraception. Dire : vous avez la contraception uniquement si je peux faire un dépistage chez vous.
Déjà, c'est un problème puisqu'il n'y a aucun lien. Et les jeunes femmes, parfois, elles font le lien en disant : oui, mais la pilule, c'est dangereux.
Donc, on va quand même vérifier que... Alors en fait que non, il y a aucun lien entre cancer et pilule. Donc c'est de nouveau induire quelque chose de malsain. Et puis
Est-ce que c'est vraiment malsain de
Enfin oui, c'est, je comprends qu'il y a une notion de contrainte et une notion de on le fait un peu, on force un petit peu, mais dans le cadre d'un dépistage d'un cancer éventuel, c'est, hmm,
y a pas une justification médicale que vous pouvez comprendre ?
À 17 ans ?
Non, pas 17 ans, mais à partir de 25 ans.
Bah à partir de 25 ans, à ce moment-là, les jeunes filles disent : je vais chez le gynécologue pour un dépistage et pour une pilule éventuellement ou juste pour un dépistage.
Mais dire : je viens pour la pilule tout à fait innocemment et se retrouver avec un dépistage imposé. Non, non, on ne fait pas.
Mais vous comprenez pourquoi ils le font ?
Ah, je comprends très bien pourquoi ils le font.
Parce que ce n'est pas un réflexe pour les femmes de se faire dépister.
C'est pas un réflexe, non, c'est pas un réflexe. C'est le gynécologue qui doit justifier son rôle d'aller gagner sa vie.
Il doit le proposer et elle peut refuser. C'est ça que vous dites ?
Ben, il doit le proposer si c'est dans les clous, si c'est dans les recommandations, si elle a vingt-cinq ans et qu'elle l'a jamais fait,
il peut expliquer : voilà, les recommandations disent que vous avez bien sûr le droit de refuser parce que c'est le droit du patient, c'est le consentement libre et éclairé.
À quoi sert ce dépistage ? Qu'est-ce qui permet d'obtenir ? Comment ça va se passer ? Vous pouvez le faire maintenant ou revenez plus tard si vous préférez le faire revenir plus tard.
Et voilà, c'est ça en fait le vrai travail. Puis même est-ce que, enfin voilà, c'est le fait de lier les deux.
Et donc finalement, qu'est-ce qui se passe vraiment dans...
Ben parfois, les jeunes femmes sont tout à fait innocentes en se disant : mais je veux au moins poser quelques questions liées à ma contraception, à ma vie sexuelle, à ce vieux monsieur ou cette vieille dame, enfin, à ses yeux.
Et on se rend compte que, pff, ils sont pas du tout formés à donner une formation à une jeune fille de 17 ans et à répondre à ses questions sur le plan sexuel.
C'est pas leur formation. Eux, ils sont là pour faire des opérations compliquées sur l'utérus quoi. Donc ça, même ça, ça n'a pas de sens.
Dans le cadre de leurs études, il n'y a pas vraiment d'aspect pédagogique, d'aspect, on va apprendre à apprendre, on va apprendre à
Ben surtout que c'est un gynécologue, c'est pas un sexologue.
Oui.
C'est deux, c'est pas les gynécologues qui vont donner des formations EVRAS. C'est deux métiers différents.
Oui, oui. Après, oui, c'est peut-être en train de changer, mais historiquement, il y a eu un déficit au niveau de ce qu'on pouvait proposer dans le public au niveau des formations EVRAS.
Donc bon, on peut comprendre que ça retombe sur les gynécologues.
Oui, sauf que c'est pas
Oui, c'est pas idéal.
Ils sont pas formés à ça. Et puis au contraire, ils peuvent même induire justement un comportement paternaliste de jugement, voilà.
Et ça va pas du tout. Et le nombre de témoignages de jeunes filles qui ont été traumatisées par un gynécologue et qui veulent plus y retourner, c'est aussi, à mon avis, plus là le problème de santé publique
que faire absolument des dépistages à des jeunes femmes.
Donc c'est un exemple de violence qui sort du cadre de l'accouchement. Est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres qui vous viennent à l'esprit ?
Alors, ce qui est aussi, enfin
questionnant, c'est justement le fait que les gynécologues se sont quelque part spécialisés dans le suivi de femmes qui n'ont pas de problème, voilà, qui viennent pour du dépistage, qui viennent pour de la contraception, qui viennent,
voilà, parce qu'elles sont à la ménopause.
Enfin voilà, des choses qui n'ont absolument rien de, qui relèvent pas du médical. Mais quand il y a un problème, là, il y a une errance thérapeutique.
Donc, par exemple, pendant des années,
il y a des femmes qui ont eu des règles hyper douloureuses,
invalidantes. Pendant trois jours, quatre jours, elles ne peuvent pas travailler, elles peuvent pas aller aux cours parce qu'elles sont terrassées par de la douleur insupportable et qui vont chez les gynécologues en leur expliquant ça.
Donc, on pourrait se dire là, il y a une pathologie, parce que c'est pas normal d'avoir une douleur pareille pour un truc qui, a priori, fonctionne bien.
Par exemple, de l'endométriose.
Par exemple. Voilà, vous voyez très bien où je veux en venir. C'est par exemple typiquement l'endométriose,
mais qui a mis des années et des années avant d'émerger comme étant un problème et une pathologie qui met toujours des années et des années avant d'être identifiée clairement par des gynécologues. Alors même
Et parfois, beaucoup de faux diagnostics, beaucoup de faux négatifs.
Voilà, et des femmes qui se retrouvent à errer de l'un à l'autre parce que malgré tout, elles se rendent bien compte qu'il y a un problème et que c'est pas normal et que on leur envoie : oui, mais c'est dans votre tête.
Mais oui, mais réfléchissez à votre relation avec votre corps, avec votre propre mère, avec, est-ce que vous avez pas eu des abus ?
Machin machin. Enfin, un discours totalement psychanalisant, psychologisant, qui renvoie aux histé- Ben oui, effectivement.
Le discours psychanalisant, c'est aussi en Belgique ou ?
Partout. Ben, je veux dire les
J'associe ça surtout à la France, moi, mais...
Oh, il y en a aussi en Belgique. C'est aussi quelque chose, c'est dans votre tête. Ça, c'est assez typique hein. Le médecin sait pas, c'est dans votre tête.
C'est vraiment un peu la réponse bateau.
C'est vrai que oui.
La réponse bateau à peu près à tout quoi. Donc, pff, alors où est l'intérêt de nouveau d'avoir des médecins qui passent leur temps à soigner des femmes qui sont pas malades et quand elles sont malades, ben c'est compliqué. Donc il y a ça.
Oui. Alors, pff,
abandonner et dire : c'est dans votre tête, bon, c'est nul. À la limite, je peux comprendre, mais c'est quand on arrive à des informations sectaires comme la psychanalyse, les trucs mère frigide, machin chouette, tout ça,
là, c'est criminel pour moi.
Mais on parlera du versant juridique peut-être un peu plus tard.
Mais donc oui, vous disiez, donc les jeunes filles qui viennent pour se plaindre de douleurs extrêmes et qui reçoivent un faux négatif dans le cadre d'un diagnostic ou une fin de non-recevoir,
c'est une forme de violence aussi, vous dites ?
Oui, ben c'est ça en fait. Et surtout sur le côté, bon à la limite, le faux négatif, soit, mais c'est voilà : non, en fait, rentrez chez vous madame, vous n'avez rien, regardez, les résultats sont négatifs.
Ben vous avez mal, c'est dans votre tête. Donc c'est une façon d'expédier ces femmes qui se retrouvent pendant, et enfin, j'en connais quelques unes, même des proches hein, à qui c'est arrivé,
où pendant dix ans, quinze ans, elles se retrouvent à errer,
comme ça jusqu'au jour où d'un seul coup, ben voilà, on tombe sur un gynécologue qui est un peu plus
outillé par rapport à ça.
Et là, ben là, ça devient évident qu'effectivement, c'était de l'endométriose et il y avait pas de contestation possible parce que les examens ont montré que c'était bien ça.
Donc oui, c'est... Et même à cette occasion-là, donc là, ça se passe pas en Belgique, mais ça se passe en France, il y a ce qu'on appelle l'affaire Daraï, Émile Daraï, qui est un ponte de la gynécologie en France
qui a été dénoncé, donc qui a travaillé à l'hôpital Tenon près de Paris pendant des années.
Il était chef de service, il donnait cours à la Sorbonne. Enfin, c'était un petit peu le ponte de la gynécologie qui s'est spécialisé en endométriose.
Et donc on pourrait se dire : bon a priori, ce monsieur-là serait bienveillant envers les femmes. Au moins, il s'est spécialisé dans quelque chose de vraiment utile, voilà.
Et en fait, il y a aujourd'hui encore trente-deux plaintes de femmes contre lui pour viol et violences parce qu'il s'est comporté de façon odieuse avec ses patientes.
J'en ai entendu parler aussi.
Voilà donc c'est même pas la garantie de se dire : Au moins, je fais quelque chose de vraiment utile et je me comporte bien.
C'est encore deux choses différentes. Donc...
Ok.
Ouais.
D'autres exemples pour qu'on fasse un petit peu le tour du paysage, d'autres exemples de violences obstétricales en dehors du cadre de l'accouchement ?
Il y a pas mal de choses qui jouent au niveau des fausses couches, donc c'est un peu plus proche de l'accouchement quand même.
Le post-partum aussi, je pense.
Le post-partum aussi, oui, mais alors la fausse couche, moi, je trouve c'est vraiment un débat, enfin qui est à la fois tabou, mais qui est quand même très pertinent à aborder.
C'est, ben qu'est-ce qui se passe en cas de fausse couche ? Donc déjà, les fausses couches, quand on sait ce que c'est, c'est quelque chose qui est la preuve que le corps fonctionne bien.
Pour faire simple, effectivement, c'est un passage souvent très douloureux pour les femmes parce qu'il y a cette perte, enfin pour le couple hein, en général, cette perte de cet enfant qui était désiré.
Enfin, il y a plein de choses qui se passent au niveau du deuil, au niveau des émotions, au niveau de la projection en tant que parent.
Enfin voilà, c'est vraiment un moment très très difficile. Et il y a une croyance qui est qu'il faut médicaliser la fausse couche.
Donc il y a une croyance qui est de dire : Ben voilà, dès qu'on a les signes qu'il va y avoir une fausse couche, des pertes de sang, le cœur du petit qui s'est arrêté,
eh ben il faut intervenir pour évacuer ce fœtus le plus vite possible en disant : Ben hop, c'est évacué, c'est hors du corps.
C'est fini, madame, vous pouvez rentrer chez vous, c'est bon, c'est réglé. Alors qu'en fait non, ce qu'il faut faire déjà, bon le corps est capable d'évacuer lui-même un embryon, un fœtus qui est mort, qui ne se développe plus.
Ça fait partie du fonctionnement normal du corps, en fait, il suffit d'attendre. Et surtout, ce qui est important à ce moment-là, c'est l'accompagnement émotionnel des femmes, c'est, des couples.
C'est de dire : Ben voilà, qu'est-ce qui va se jouer ? Il faut pas se précipiter au niveau médical. Il faut voir ce que la femme veut vraiment.
Est-ce qu'elle veut attendre un petit peu le temps de digérer la mauvaise nouvelle, de préparer son deuil, de... Il y a tout ça qui devrait être mis en place avant de se précipiter pour lui donner des cachets pour évacuer l'embryon.
Et ça, il y a encore vraiment quelque chose à... enfin, à construire dans les hôpitaux pour prendre en compte plutôt cet aspect émotionnel plutôt que l'aspect médical.
Et moi, j'étais étonnée de voir le nombre de femmes qui croyaient que d'office, il fallait médicaliser une fausse couche parce que c'était soi-disant dangereux.
Oui, j'aurais une question là-dessus. Déjà, est-ce que vous pouvez rappeler le pourcentage ? Puisque vous disiez que c'est la preuve que le corps fonctionne bien, une fausse couche.
Est-ce que vous pouvez rappeler le pourcentage de grossesses qui débouchent sur une fausse couche ?
Alors ben, les chiffres cités, c'est en tout cas dans les trois premiers mois de la grossesse, qui est vraiment la période la plus sensible, puisque finalement, dès le départ, des embryons qui se développent pas bien.
Donc, on dit c'est une sur quatre qui s'arrête.
Ok. Donc c'est quand même significatif.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est même pour ça qu'on dit aux femmes : N'annoncez pas votre grossesse, ce qui est une idiotie hein.
N'annoncez pas votre grossesse avant les trois mois parce qu'il y a de tels risques que la grossesse s'arrête, qu'on préfère dire aux femmes : Taisez-vous, n'embêtez pas les gens avec ça, ça va être gênant après.
Et donc taisez-vous, surtout, attendez. Et alors après, il y a encore un pourcentage plus faible, qui est de l'ordre de 10 %.
Ça dépend un petit peu des situations.
Je pense que l'idée, c'est surtout de dire : Tempérez vos attentes tant que vous n'êtes pas sûr. Parce que vous parliez de la violence psychologique de la perte d'un enfant à venir.
Voilà, tempérez vos attentes tant que vous avez pas passé les trois mois...
C'est ce qu'on dit aux femmes. D'un autre côté, vous imaginez, vous allez, vous, 'fin...
Non, je peux pas imaginer.
Oui oui, c'est ça. Vous avez une collègue, par exemple, vous avez une collègue qui est enceinte, qui débute sa grossesse, qui est épuisée, qui vomit tout le temps,
qui va pas du tout bien parce que sa grossesse est quand même un petit peu plus compliquée.
Voilà, des symptômes de grossesse tout à fait normaux, peut-être des migraines, ça va pas, des sautes d'humeur, des problèmes de digestion.
Elle doit elle-même faire attention à ce qu'elle mange, parce que là aussi, il y a tout un débat sur ce qu'elle peut manger, ce qu'elle peut pas manger, l'alcool, pas l'alcool, tout ça, tout ça, tout ça.
Pendant trois mois, on arrive à Noël, fête de Noël au boulot et tout, elle doit se cacher pour pas boire de l'alcool et inventer n'importe quel truc pour dire que la moitié du buffet, elle y touche pas.
Et en fait, on voit cette collègue un petit peu bizarre là, pendant plusieurs semaines et puis d'un seul coup, paf, elle fait une fausse couche.
Et donc elle vit ce deuil de cette fausse couche qui... Et en fait, pendant plusieurs mois, vous êtes à côté d'une femme qui vit des trucs extraordinaires, mais elle peut pas parler, elle peut rien dire.
Et elle doit cacher tout ça à son entourage.
Je comprends, ouais.
Et voyez, qu'est-ce qui est le mieux psychologiquement, en fait ? Donc c'est...
Non mais donc tout ça pour dire que c'est à la fois relativement banal et en même temps absolument traumatisant, violent psychologiquement.
Là où je voulais réagir aussi sur le fait que vous disiez qu'on peut tout à fait faire ça encore une fois seul à la maison et pas forcément devoir médicaliser la chose, aller à l'hôpital.
Mais en fait juste pour la gestion de : Mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le fœtus une fois qu'il est sorti ? Là, rien que pour ça, j'aurais envie de conseiller d'aller à l'hôpital. Mais...
Alors oui.
Parce que ça doit pas être facile psychologiquement.
Ben oui et non. Enfin moi, j'ai fait une fausse couche tardive où j'ai perdu deux jumeaux à quatre mois de grossesse.
Pour moi, c'était... Alors c'était quand même une question, moi, qui était très, très concrète hein. C'est si on les enlève à l'hôpital, c'est un déchet médical.
On les met dans une petite boîte jaune et c'est parti avec les déchets médicaux. Est-ce que c'est ça qu'on veut pour son fœtus ou pas ?
Est-ce que c'est plus facile à gérer ou pas ? Oui.
Oui, c'est ça. Et moi, non, moi, je voulais pas ça. J'ai préféré moi-même voir mes fœtus et les enterrer.
D'accord.
Mais ça, c'est une question de nouveau, c'est une question personnelle.
Personnelle, oui.
Et quand j'ai demandé à l'hôpital : Est-ce que je peux récupérer mes fœtus et partir avec ? Elle dit : Ah ben non. Ah ben non, le protocole, c'est qu'ils sortent pas.
C'est un déchet médical. On n'emporte pas un déchet médical de l'hôpital,
c'est interdit. Et donc une des raisons pour lesquelles je suis restée à la maison pour accoucher de mes fœtus morts à la maison, c'était pour pouvoir récupérer les corps.
Mais ça, c'est vraiment une question personnelle de rapport avec son corps, avec ses choix, avec... Et si l'hôpital était un peu plus souple par rapport à ça, peut-être que ça faciliterait aussi les choses.
Mais voilà, c'était pour plus tard. Des fœtus plus grands, enfin plus âgés. Là, il y a des limites où on peut les enterrer, on peut--
mais ça reste des questions qui relèvent plus de la philosophie presque que de la médecine, mais malgré tout, la médecine, voilà, a parfois une contrainte par rapport à ce genre de choses.
Alors, on prétend que les femmes sont traumatisées en voyant l'embryon, le fœtus, tout ça.
Moi, ça me traumatiserait, je pense.
Ouais, mais je sais pas. En même temps, enfin, il y a des hommes qui sont traumatisés en voyant du sang des règles, donc—
Je suis traumatisé, c'est pas drôle, non, j'exagère, mais en tout cas, ça me ferait pas plaisir quoi.
Bah ça, c'est une question aussi. Bah se poser la question quand on annonce une fausse couche, qu'est-ce qu'on veut ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut ? Enfin, moi, c'est--
ce qui m'avait frappée, parce que c'est aussi un questionnement que j'ai eu pendant longtemps, c'est, je sais pas si vous vous souvenez au moment de l'affaire Julie et Melissa, dans les années nonante.
J'étais pas né.
Voilà. En fait, moi, j'étais jeune à ce moment-là, donc c'était... Enfin, on voyait ça à la télévision, commission d'enquête, on en parlait à tous les journaux, etc., etc.
Le roi qui intervient. Enfin bref, c'est vraiment le gros truc médiatique qui dure pendant des mois. On retrouve le corps de Julie et Melissa.
Juste pour faire une petite parenthèse hein. On finit par retrouver le corps de Julie et Melissa en mauvais état.
Il y a autopsie, etc. Et finalement, moi, ce qui m'a frappée à l'époque, pourtant, j'étais jeune, c'était les parents de Julie et Melissa.
Donc les mamans auraient voulu voir le corps de leur fille et ça leur a été interdit. Donc, on s'est débattu en commission parlementaire de pourquoi la justice, même ça, la justice a refusé aux parents.
Enfin... Et moi, ça m'avait questionnée en me disant : « Mais tiens... » Voilà, c'était un petit truc qui était resté dans le coin de ma tête.
Pourquoi ce besoin des mères de voir le corps de leur enfant ?
Et pourquoi le besoin de l'interdire ?
Et pourquoi le besoin de l'interdire ? Soi-disant pour pas traumatiser. Mais non, enfin. Et alors après, j'ai commencé à lire toute une série de travaux justement sur
l'accès, parce que la même question s'est posée en cas d'accouchement, le bébé meurt à l'accouchement pendant très longtemps.
On a retiré les bébés morts des mères pour pas qu'elles voient leur bébé mort. Mais c'était très compliqué pour elles d'arriver à accepter que le bébé était mort alors qu'elles l'ont même pas vu.
Et donc, il y a quand même eu à un moment donné un questionnement sur : est-ce que c'est pertinent d'aller vraiment cacher la mort aux mères ?
Alors que bon, pourquoi pas ? Et je crois qu'il y a vraiment un questionnement plus... Ben oui, plus philosophique, psychologique.
Qu'est-ce qui se joue à ce moment-là ? Qu'est-ce qui se joue au moment du deuil ? Qu'est-ce qui se joue par rapport au corps, par rapport à la mort, par rapport à plein de choses ?
Donc oui, moi, je crois qu'il faut pas être catégorique sur le mode—
Non, pas catégorique, mais—
Voilà, moi, je—
C'est personnel.
C'est personnel. Je crois que ça fait partie du questionnement à voir et ça fait partie du questionnement à se poser quand on est confronté en tant que parent à une fausse couche et au corps ou—
au fait que le bébé est mort à la naissance, ça arrive malheureusement parfois.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait quoi à ce moment-là ? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Est-ce que... Voilà, ça fait partie de la vie.
Et donc le versant philosophique et même psychologique, vous disiez, et ça même, je pense, ça dépasse le cadre des accouchements, le cadre obstétrical.
Je pense que de manière générale, les médecins pourraient être formés à ces enjeux-là. Ce qui m'amène à la dernière question que je voulais poser vis-à-vis des violences obstétricales : le post-partum.
C'est aussi un truc qui, apparemment, si je comprends bien, est assez mal géré, assez mal accompagné.
Oui, alors le post-partum, c'est quoi ? Ben c'est ça, c'est vraiment tout le paradoxe. Donc la grossesse, les femmes sont vraiment mises sous tutelle, elles sont considérées comme des petites filles, on leur interdit plein de choses,
de manger ceci, de manger cela, de faire ça, de faire ça.
Enfin, c'est vraiment une espèce de demi sous tutelle, d'infantilisation totale des femmes enceintes avec des contrôles médicaux à n'en plus finir.
Arrive l'accouchement, médicalisation totale de plein d'intervenants qui viennent s'occuper de cet accouchement qui pourrait déraper.
Et puis voilà, madame, vous avez votre bébé, vous rentrez chez vous, c'est fini. Rentrez chez vous, tout va bien. Et c'est tout.
Alors qu'en fait, c'est à ce moment-là que tout se pose, que tout se joue. D'abord, l'éventuel traumatisme de l'accouchement, ben les suites de ça, notamment des violences obstétricales, mais pas que.
Comment les femmes gèrent ça ? Comment elles gèrent la fatigue ? Comment elles gèrent le bébé qui arrive ? Comment elles gèrent l'allaitement ?
Comment elles gèrent les nuits qui ne se passent pas bien ? Comment elles gèrent toutes les questions qu'elles ont par rapport à un petit bébé qui débarque dans la vie ?
On n'a jamais vu un bébé avant ça. Et il faut pouvoir assurer ben la vie de ce bébé, ce qui est quand même un questionnement assez fondamental.
Comment on gère le couple dans tout ça ? Comment on gère tout quoi ? Enfin, tout, tout, c'est tout un chamboulement ben total de sa vie avec l'arrivée du premier bébé.
Et là, ben les femmes sont seules. Voilà. Débrouillez-vous madame, rentrez chez vous, tout va bien. On a
évidemment psychologisé la situation en parlant du baby-blues, que les femmes, les hormones, de toute façon, elles ont leurs crises de larmes et c'est normal et on s'en fiche, c'est leurs hormones.
Bon, c'est tout à fait questionnable, évidemment. C'est pas du tout—enfin moi, c'est pas du tout mon interprétation que j'ai de la situation.
C'est plutôt cette espèce de retentissement qu'il y a de façon globale dans leur vie, à la fois le suivi de l'accouchement qui parfois s'est, enfin dans de nombreux cas, s'est mal passé.
Et puis cette conjonction avec l'arrivée du bébé. Et puis alors après, il y a cette espèce de sentiment de solitude qui peut s'installer et qui peut retentir avec d'autres éléments et qui peut provoquer une dépression dans les mois qui suivent.
Et donc c'est effectivement toute cette espèce d'abandon du jour au lendemain où voilà, vous avez le bébé, débrouillez-vous, vous êtes censée avoir l'instinct maternel qui vous permettrait comme ça de tout inventer, ce qui n'est pas le cas. Donc c'est—
Et vous, vous catégorisez ça comme une violence obstétricale ?
Ben je crois que
c'est pas en tant que telle une violence obstétricale. C'est une espèce d'abandon des femmes qui est basé sur de nouveau une conception sexiste qui est de dire : elles ont l'instinct maternel, donc elles vont savoir faire.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas. On n'a pas d'instinct maternel. On ne sait pas spontanément faire un biberon comme ça. Alors c'est tout un apprentissage.
Et cette notion d'apprentissage n'est pas reconnue pour les femmes. Elles sont censées savoir faire les choses comme ça.
Et puis c'est tout le soutien. Dans une société plus traditionnelle, on voit qu'il y a toute la communauté qui se met en place pour soutenir les femmes, pour soutenir les bébés, pour apporter de l'aide.
Et ici, chez nous, ben les femmes sont seules. Voilà, avec le mari qui très vite repart travailler parce qu'il n'y a pas un congé de paternité suffisamment long.
Et quand bien même il est là, ben il n'est pas nécessairement plus outillé que la femme elle-même par rapport au bébé. Il n'y a pas grand-chose qui se fait quoi.
Donc effectivement, il y a toujours vraiment quelque chose à se mettre en place.
Et on a un pourcentage là-dessus, des chiffres sur le nombre de femmes que ça concerne ? Est-ce que c'est une écrasante majorité ? Est-ce que c'est—
Toutes les femmes se retrouvent seules à peu près. Il faut être clair, il y a quand même très peu de femmes qui peuvent se vanter d'avoir un entourage bienveillant, soutenant, des gens qui se mobilisent,
les grands-parents, les frères, les sœurs, les copines, tout, qui viennent en permanence, qui assurent pendant les nuits.
Enfin, il y a très très peu de femmes chez qui c'est le cas. Il y a aussi peu de femmes qui connaissent les éventuelles ressources de Kraamzorg, comme il y a en Flandre, qui sont des
aides familiales spécialisées en bébés qui peuvent venir les soutenir pendant parfois plusieurs heures par jour.
Et puis il y a ce discours, ben oui, la femme pleure, ben c'est ses hormones quoi. Donc il y a même pas une volonté d'aller plus loin que dépasser cette idée que c'est normal quoi.
Donc oui, ça touche vraiment toutes les femmes.
Toutes les femmes, ok.
Alors sur la dépression en tant que telle, oui, il y a des chiffres un peu plus bas, c'est plutôt 15, 20 % des femmes qui font une dépression, mais là, c'est vraiment, vraiment grave quoi.
Donc elles doivent vraiment—
Donc on parle de post-partum dans tous les cas ou juste dans le cadre de la dépression ?
Le post-partum, le post-partum, c'est ce qui suit l'accouchement hein. Donc c'est vraiment voilà, la période qui suit pendant plusieurs mois ou—
Vous ne médicalisez pas le terme, vous vraiment—
Non, c'est vraiment un terme—
La temporalité.
Voilà, c'est ça. C'est ce qui suit l'accouchement. Voilà, ça, c'est vraiment—alors c'est la dépression du post-partum quand il y a dépression.
Oui voilà c'est ça. C'est plutôt à ça que je faisais référence.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et ça, c'est plutôt 15, 20 % des femmes.
D'accord, ok. Très bien. Vous êtes juriste, ça tombe bien. On parlait par exemple tout à l'heure de, voilà, ce chef de service, ce boucher.
On parlait de cet autre chef de service spécialisé dans l'endométriose que plein de patientes allaient voir et qui était, ben violées.
Qu'est-ce qui existe en termes de précédents, en termes de bases juridiques pour sanctionner les violences obstétricales de manière générale ?
Et puis on va être plus spécifique après.
Alors, il y a pas de loi qui condamne les violences obstétricales. Il faut être clair, c'est assez clair. Voilà, merci, vous pouvez rentrer chez vous.
Non, non, ben c'est une notion qui est émergente, comme on dit. Donc il y a eu le fameux rapport du Sénat qui a pointé toute une série de mesures à prendre dans plein de domaines différents.
Donc c'est vraiment, je vous recommande de le lire. Il y a 93 mesures, donc c'est vraiment, ça balaye tout quoi : la formation des médecins, l'organisation des hôpitaux, les droits des patients, enfin tout ça.
Ça date de quand ce rapport du Sénat ?
De janvier là maintenant, de janvier 2024. Donc ça, ça vient de sortir il y a deux mois. Et donc c'est vraiment un timing idéal puisque c'est avant les élections.
Donc on peut supposer que tous les partis ont voté ce rapport et donc tous les partis vont tout mettre dans leur programme pour bien sûr faire la révolution dès les prochains gouvernements.
On peut bien sûr espérer, mais voilà, on reste positif. Alors en termes de droit pur, alors il faut s'appuyer sur autre chose.
C'est ce que je dis hein, c'est que si on a vraiment été victime de maltraitance, il faut s'appuyer sur ce qui existe dans le droit pénal comme les coups et blessures, comme les viols, les mutilations sexuelles.
Donc voilà, il y a d'autres articles du droit pénal qu'on pourrait mobiliser pour déposer plainte.
En termes de droit civil, c'est plutôt les erreurs médicales, demander une intervention pour couvrir les dommages et intérêts en cas d'erreur médicale.
Et puis il y a éventuellement porter plainte à l'Ordre des médecins pour une sanction du médecin. Bon. Maintenant, je vais être claire sur le fait qu'il y a jamais rien qui aboutit.
Voilà. Déposer plainte à la police parce que le médecin a mis ses doigts dans mon vagin au moment de mon accouchement, c'est quand même un peu compliqué de faire reconnaître ça comme un viol.
Une épisiotomie, c'est effectivement, ça tombe dans la définition des mutilations sexuelles. C'est compliqué de nouveau de faire reconnaître ça.
Enfin voilà. Et moi, je suis pas tellement, même si je suis juriste, je suis pas tellement à vouloir pousser les femmes absolument
à utiliser la justice dans l'état actuel du droit, parce que les chances de réussite sont très très faibles et risquent vraiment de s'épuiser, et ça coûte cher pour finalement pas grand-chose.
Moi, je préfère de loin agir au niveau politique pour changer de façon globale et systémique la société—
La législation.
La législation, le fonctionnement. Et c'est pas que la législation, c'est aussi le fonctionnement des hôpitaux, le financement des hôpitaux, qu'est-ce qu'on finance, qu'est-ce qu'on finance pas.
L'enseignement, la formation.
L'enseignement, la formation des futurs médecins, des futures sages-femmes, l'organisation des maternités de telle sorte que les femmes puissent accoucher de façon plus libre et de façon moins protocolaire.
Voilà, dégager du temps pour les sages-femmes pour accompagner les femmes. Donc non pas des sages-femmes qui courent entre plusieurs femmes qui accouchent, mais dire le principe de une femme, une sage-femme.
Donc une sage-femme est attachée, entre guillemets, à une seule femme qui accouche et l'accompagne en permanence jusqu'à la naissance.
C'est l'application des recommandations du KCE qui sont là hein, sur un accouchement normal, sur le dépistage du cancer, enfin sur tout ça.
Donc il suffit juste d'appliquer ce qui existe déjà. Et moi, c'est plus là où moi, je verrais un changement que d'essayer de saisir la justice pour une issue quand même plutôt hypothétique.
Ok. Donc pas de base juridique à proprement parler, des grandes difficultés à poursuivre éventuellement les médecins incriminés.
Est-ce qu'il existe malgré tout quelques précédents, quelques rares cas de, voilà, par exemple, vous disiez d'exclusion de l'Ordre des médecins.
Est-ce que c'est des choses qu'on a pu voir en Belgique ?
En fait, non.
Il y a vraiment rien.
Et alors il y a plein de femmes. Enfin, j'ai suivi quelques affaires, peut-être un peu plus en France qu'en Belgique, mais enfin, la logique est vraiment la même dans les deux pays,
qui ont été effectivement déposer plainte à l'Ordre des médecins pour essayer quand même de sensibiliser
en disant : « Mais ça va pas du tout, ça va pas du tout.
» Et en fait, on est face à,
ben de nouveau ce principe de confraternité où on se défend l'un l'autre. Et après tout, ce qu'elle dénonce, c'est simplement des pratiques normales qui ont lieu dans les hôpitaux parce que c'est la norme hein, les violences obstétricales.
Et donc non, moi, j'ai jamais vu une patiente qui aboutit à une condamnation d'un médecin.
Ok.
Pour être claire.
Ok, ok.
Donc oui, c'est par d'autres méthodes où finalement, petit à petit, certains, quand il y a une conscience des directeurs d'hôpitaux, d'aller pousser certains médecins vraiment problématiques à l'extérieur. Mais enfin
j'avais encore un exemple, moi, qui m'a révoltée, c'est que je vais pas citer l'hôpital parce qu'on va
pas l'identifier, mais on m'a cité un cas en Belgique d'un anesthésiste qui chaque fois qu'il mettait une péridurale, allait tripoter les seins de la patiente.
Bon, ça se sait. On commence à dire : « Ça va pas du tout » et on commence à le pousser tout doucement vers la sortie parce que ça fait quand même un peu tache dans le service, quelqu'un qui fonctionne comme ça.
Dès qu'il était dehors, il s'est fait engager par l'hôpital d'en face qui cherchait un anesthésiste. Donc voilà, on en est là. Donc c'est-
On n'est pas tellement dans une culture médicale où on forme des dossiers-
Voilà, voilà, voilà.
Personnes problématiques.
Voilà.
Ouais, ouais. C'est pas seulement en Belgique, ça, malheureusement. Donc voilà, cadre légal, on a dit que c'était un peu le désert, malheureusement.
Et donc vous misez plutôt sur l'avenir et sur construire un,
un meilleur lendemain. Dans l'histoire récente, par exemple, les accouchements, les accompagnements de gynécologues obstétriciens dans le cadre du Covid, par exemple, à quoi est-ce que ça ressemblait ?
C'était quand même un moment très très compliqué pour les femmes. Le Covid, c'était... Bon déjà, ça se passait au sein des hôpitaux, là même où tous les patients Covid arrivaient.
Donc il y avait quand même une espèce de tension générale. C'était quand même une période très très compliquée pour tout le monde et en particulier pour les hôpitaux.
Et puis très vite, c'est rentré en clash avec l'organisation des maternités où il y avait ces sages-femmes qui couraient entre plusieurs patientes, ces patientes qui étaient là sachant pas trop ce qui allait se passer.
Et puis, il y a des choses vraiment problématiques qui ont été mises en place, comme le fait d'obliger les patientes à porter un masque, par exemple.
Alors, il faut imaginer un accouchement où c'est vraiment un effort colossal à faire et on demandait à ces femmes de garder un masque pendant tout leur accouchement.
Donc ça, c'était clairement de l'ordre de la violence obstétricale. On leur interdisait parfois même le fait d'être accompagnées par leur mari ou par leur compagne parce qu'on considérait que c'était une personne et pas plus.
Et donc, il y a des accouchements où elles se sont retrouvées toutes seules, voilà, totalement démunies parce que même leur compagnon ne pouvait pas être là.
Ou alors, ils pouvaient être là à l'accouchement, mais ils devaient partir genre après deux heures. Donc dès qu'elles rentraient elles-mêmes dans leur chambre, ils devaient partir.
Donc ils ne pouvaient pas assister au premier jour. Enfin voilà, il y a eu plein de-
Ça fait un post-partum encore plus violent.
Voilà, exactement. Enfin d'autres ont dit : « Finalement, ce n'est pas plus mal quand le mari a pu rester ou leur compagne, on peut rester.
C'est bien. Au moins, toute la famille ne vient pas débarquer. Donc ça, c'est bien. » Certaines ont vécu ça positivement.
Donc, mais voilà. Moi, je trouve qu'il y a quand même eu beaucoup de choses vraiment problématiques dans le fait que plein de femmes ont été vraiment abandonnées ou ont dû accoucher dans des conditions vraiment difficiles à ce moment-là.
Et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui a aussi poussé la Plateforme pour une naissance respectée à faire une étude pour objectiver ce genre de pratiques dans certains hôpitaux.
Oui.
Donc oui.
Après, le Covid, c'était beaucoup d'improvisation, beaucoup de sur le tas, des décisions... Petite parenthèse : il y a encore partout en Belgique des petits panneaux pour dire : « Gardez vos distances d'un mètre cinquante. »
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est toujours là, c'est très bizarre. Mais ouais, donc beaucoup... Bon, effectivement, je comprends que la situation était assez catastrophique.
Difficile de juger en même temps pour dire : « C'était évident, il fallait faire mieux. »
Oui, ben alors moi, je trouve que ça a permis aussi de se poser la question : qu'est-ce qu'on aurait dû faire et qu'est-ce qui permettrait, si on tire les enseignements de cette période-là, qu'est-ce qui permettrait d'améliorer les choses ?
Par exemple, le fait qu'il y ait ces ruptures, cette rupture... Moi, j'ai pas mal discuté avec un gynécologue à l'époque, il y en a qui sont vraiment chouettes, qui réfléchissent vraiment bien.
On va en parler, on va en parler.
Oui oui. Et qui me disait : « Mais pourquoi
le mari doit partir après deux heures
? » Il me dit : « Le problème, c'est ce changement de service, c'est que les sages-femmes qui vont accompagner les femmes au moment de l'accouchement, ce ne sont pas les mêmes qui vont après passer dans les chambres.
» Et donc on multiplie chaque fois le nombre d'intervenants. Donc, on peut se poser la question : est-ce que c'est pertinent qu'il y ait autant d'intervenants médicaux qui suivent
les femmes qui accouchent au point où on exclut le mari parce qu'il n'a pas sa place ?
Donc, on pourrait aussi se poser la question de réorganiser le service de telle sorte que finalement, les femmes qui accouchent voient une seule sage-femme ou deux maximum et que ce soit chaque fois les mêmes personnes qui les accompagnent.
C'est aussi une façon de résoudre ce problème d'un très grand nombre d'intervenants qui pourraient se contaminer l'un l'autre.
Donc, ce serait intéressant d'aller tirer ces enseignements-là jusqu'au bout pour voir comment on pourrait améliorer les choses qui pourraient être même positives dans une période où il n'y a plus de Covid.
En parlant d'expérience positive, est-ce que du coup, vous auriez des recommandations pour les éventuelles personnes enceintes qui nous écoutent ou futures personnes enceintes ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des hôpitaux, des sages-femmes, des gynécologues en particulier, des procédures ? Vous parliez de privatisation dans le cas de votre accouchement.
Qu'est-ce que vous auriez comme recommandation pour les personnes qui nous écoutent ?
Alors, les recommandations, c'est... Moi, je trouve que si c'est un accouchement, on va dire normal, qu'il n'y a pas de pathologie particulière, déjà, s'adresser plutôt à des sages-femmes qu'à des gynécologues.
Trouver des sages-femmes qui sont
vraiment plutôt formées pour accompagner un accouchement normal, qui vont avoir des conseils
peut-être plus pertinents sur plein de petites questions plus ou moins importantes que les femmes pourraient se poser pendant leur grossesse, d'avoir leur propre sage-femme au moment de l'accouchement.
Il y a plusieurs méthodes. Soit on accouche à domicile avec des sages-femmes spécialisées pour l'accouchement à domicile.
Il y en a une série en Belgique. Ou bien, on peut aller en maison de naissance. Il y a Erasme, ici à Bruxelles, qui a le Cocon.
C'est vraiment un endroit un peu comme à la maison, mais
au sein de l'hôpital. Il y a une maison de naissance à Namur. Enfin voilà, il y a plusieurs maisons de naissance qui existent, qui permettent vraiment de faire un accompagnement très intéressant
des femmes qui veulent plutôt s'orienter vers un accouchement naturel.
Ça peut être effectivement le plateau technique, donc venir avec sa propre sage-femme dans un hôpital et privatiser une salle d'accouchement.
Voilà. Et alors après, il y a certains hôpitaux, mais ça, il faut vraiment bien se renseigner, qui ont des pratiques plus respectueuses que d'autres.
Il faut se renseigner.
Oui oui oui.
Les ressources, elles sont disponibles ?
C'est ça qui est compliqué en fait, c'est qu'il n'y a pas vraiment une liste et c'est compliqué. Donc moi, c'est vrai quand on me pose la question : où vais-je accoucher ?
Moi, je préfère à Bruxelles, en tout cas, recommander plutôt Saint-Pierre Erasme plutôt que Saint-Luc, par exemple. Pour dire les choses clairement, au hasard. Voilà.
Mais voilà, ça dépend. On parle des gens qui ont eu une très bonne expérience à Saint-Luc. Moi, je dis pas, mais voilà, les échos qui en sortent, c'est qu'il y a quand même certains endroits qui sont plus accueillants et respectueux que d'autres.
Je me demande si je suis pas né à Saint-Luc. Je suis même pas très sûr. Je ne me souviens plus.
C'est peut-être-- ouais, c'est peut-être que ça a changé aussi.
Oui, c'est vrai. Mais ok. Mais donc, sans indiscrétion, par exemple, la question de privatiser une salle, ça demande un investissement budgétaire ou c'est abordable ?
Oh, c'est abordable. Souvent, il y a même des mutuelles qui interviennent. Donc oui, c'est pas... Enfin, évidemment, le frein, c'est-- bon, il y a un frein financier parce qu'effectivement, payer sa propre sage-femme,
souvent, elles sont déconventionnées.
Enfin bon voilà, c'est vrai que c'est un peu plus cher. C'est aussi une des raisons pour laquelle il faudrait agir au niveau politique pour permettre à toutes les femmes, y compris celles qui n'ont pas d'argent, de trouver une sage-femme.
Encore qu'il y a des caisses de solidarité. Enfin, ça arrange. Il y a quand même peu de femmes qui se retrouvent exclues du système si elles veulent le faire pour des raisons financières.
C'est un peu plus cher, pas excessivement cher.
Pas excessivement cher. Et puis, il y a une série de mutuelles qui interviennent sur ça aussi. Donc l'un dans l'autre, c'est abordable.
Et puis, c'est aussi une question qu'on peut se poser. C'est : OK, peut-être qu'il faut payer cinq cents... Imaginons qu'on ait pas d'intervention et qu'il faille sortir cinq cents euros.
Cinq cents euros pour un accouchement qui arrive une fois dans la vie. Quand on voit ce qu'on dépense pour un mariage, ce qu'on dépense pour un smartphone.
C'est aussi à un moment donné un choix qu'on fait. Où met-on les priorités quand il faut payer quelque chose ? Donc moi, je ne suis pas totalement...
Enfin voilà, pour moi, ça fait partie des choix de vie de se dire : on va plutôt investir là qu'ailleurs quoi.
Alors là, on va peut-être sentir mon inexpérience totale. De ce que je comprends, généralement, pour les personnes enceintes qui vont consulter un gynécologue ou une gynécologue,
il y a rapidement la notion de on va fixer une date pour l'accouchement.
Oui.
Est-ce que c'est... J'imagine que ce n'est pas la même chose quand on se dirige plutôt vers une sage-femme.
Alors il y a déjà un truc très marrant, entre guillemets, marrant en Belgique, c'est que quand on compare la Belgique et la France, en Belgique, on accouche une semaine plus tôt.
Voilà. On donne la date, vous êtes en Belgique, vous êtes enceinte,
la gynécologue va prendre des petits papiers pour faire le calcul, la petite roulette là pour faire le calcul de la date présumée d'accouchement, donc une date qui est en fait une semaine avant la France.
Ce qui explique que, c'est très bizarre hein, j'ai jamais compris pourquoi. Donc ça fait dix ans que j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi cette différence d'une semaine, personne n'est capable de me répondre.
Mais ce qui a quand même une incidence très forte, qui est le taux de déclenchement en Belgique, qui est un record du monde à cause de ça.
On considère que ben voilà ma date c'est on va dire le trente juin et le trente juin le bébé n'est pas là, on déclenche. Voilà.
Ok. Déclenchement, vous incluez ça dans les violences ou bien ?
Alors si, de nouveau, c'est on se pose la question du consentement et de la pertinence médicale.
Est-ce que c'est pertinent médicalement de déclencher ? Alors là, on se pose la question vraiment, on fait une échographie, on vérifie l'état du placenta, du bébé, est-ce que tout va bien ?
Si tout va bien, que le placenta est bon, etc., on attendra un peu et c'est tout. Il n'y a pas de raison de précipiter les choses.
Et donc là arrive la question logistique de oui, mais il y a d'autres femmes qui attendent, qui ont rendez-vous demain, donc bon, et puis il faut en gérer d'autres cas, donc bon, c'est bien que ça arrive maintenant quand même.
Oui, il y a ça, puis aussi la pression de l'entourage. Moi, je me rappelle ma première grossesse, mais tout le monde m'enquiquinait parce que j'avais eu le malheur de donner la date présumée d'accouchement naïvement.
Mais c'était tout le monde : « Et quoi ? T'as pas encore accouché ? Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ? » Donc il est quand même né dix jours plus tard.
Pendant dix jours, moi, j'ai-- enfin à un moment donné, j'ai arrêté le téléphone, j'ai arrêté tout parce que c'était plus possible de vivre avec une pression pareille de gens qui venaient tout le temps me demander s'il était né ou pas quoi.
Donc il y a ça aussi. Moi, je conseille aux femmes, surtout ne donnez pas la date présumée d'accouchement à personne. Dites un mois plus tard pour avoir la paix quoi, parce que c'est...
enfin rien que ça quoi, c'est enquiquinant quoi.
Oui. Et du coup si on ne passe pas par un ou une gynécologue et qu'on préfère aller dans la direction d'une sage-femme ?
Les sages-femmes vont donner la même date, mais elles vont probablement relativiser en disant ben voilà, c'est-- en fait une naissance normale, c'est entre trente-sept semaines et quarante-deux semaines d'aménorrhée.
Donc c'est ça la fenêtre d'accouchement idéale, sachant que la première naissance est souvent un petit peu plus tard que les suivantes, à quelques jours près hein.
Donc tant qu'on reste dans cette fenêtre trente-sept semaines quarante-deux, on reste dans les clous. Et donc donner une date qui est déterminée par la date d'ovulation présumée de la, enfin la relation sexuelle, il y a...
enfin ça n'a même pas de sens quoi. Donc voilà, c'est vraiment plutôt une période, on va dire, qui est la période plus sensible où après on accouche.
Il y a de la flexibilité du côté des sages-femmes de manière générale pour dire dans ces eaux-là, je ferai en sorte d'être disponible, de venir à domicile ou de venir au bloc opératoire privatisé si besoin.
Et c'est là aussi que se joue finalement ce côté financement des sages-femmes parce que finalement, elles vont se retrouver de garde pendant
plusieurs semaines, peut-être à ne pas pouvoir partir à l'étranger en vacances, enfin tout ce qu'on veut, parce qu'elles savent qu'il y a une patiente qui est sur le point d'accoucher.
Comment on rémunère ça
? Et donc là aussi, elle se pose une question de la sécurité sociale, du financement des sages-femmes, du fait que la plupart,
en fait, elles vivotent sans gagner beaucoup d'argent parce que justement, ça leur prend énormément de temps, ça a un impact énorme sur leur vie qui n'est pas du tout valorisé.
Elles ne peuvent pas partir en vacances quoi.
Voilà. Alors qu'un gynécologue ne se pose pas toutes ces questions existentielles. C'est on fixe la date et si ce n'est pas cette date-là, on va déclencher ou bien on fait une césarienne et voilà problème résolu quoi.
Le plan de replacement sera là.
Voilà, c'est ça quoi. Donc c'est quand même plein de choses qui se jouent aussi à ce niveau-là.
Très bien. On va bientôt devoir se quitter Marie-Hélène. Merci pour cet entretien. Est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à rajouter, des points qu'on aurait peut-être oublié d'évoquer ?
Oh là là. Comme ça...
Vous pouvez plugger votre livre, vous pouvez plugger votre chaîne YouTube.
Oui, voilà. Ça, effectivement, oui, oui. Je ne fais pas qu'en promo. Donc ce que je peux ajouter, c'est que oui, il y a eu un changement récent.
C'est que moi, j'ai-- pendant cinq, six ans, j'ai vraiment tenu ce blog Marie Accouche-là, d'abord sur le blog du Monde et puis sur le blog WordPress, mais qui était un peu l'initiative de toutes ces dénonciations sur les violences obstétricales.
Puis j'ai publié mon livre en deux mille dix-huit, donc Accouchement : Les femmes méritent mieux chez Michalon. Puis j'ai fait une pause en fait, voilà, pour un tas de raisons.
J'ai un petit peu levé le pied par rapport à toutes ces questions-là. Et là maintenant, je me relance de nouveau dans ces questions d'accouchement en ouvrant une chaîne YouTube.
Donc je viens de l'ouvrir il y a quelques jours où je passe au format vidéo. Pourquoi ? Parce que je me suis rendu compte que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui, c'était plus la vidéo que le texte hein.
C'était vraiment juste du texte en fait mon blog. Et mon fils, mon fameux fils dont j'ai parlé de mon accouchement là au début de-
Celui qui est né il y a longtemps.
Celui qui est né voilà en deux mille douze, qui a quand même un petit peu mine de rien provoqué tout ça sans le vouloir hein.
Il est très charmant ce garçon. Aujourd'hui, il a onze ans, presque douze ans et il est cette génération TikTok, short, réseaux sociaux, vidéos, montage vidéo, effets spéciaux, tout ça.
Et ben voilà, il me sert de conseiller principal sur ma chaîne YouTube pour me conseiller le format, les incrustations, les montages, les montages qu'il ne trouve pas assez dynamiques à son goût, mais ça va.
Voilà, je me lance dans ma chaîne YouTube. Donc Marie Accouche-là sur YouTube.
C'est toute une formation hein, plein de choses à apprendre quand on se lance. Super. Merci beaucoup Marie-Hélène.
Avec plaisir.
On se retrouve très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode. Voilà, j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu. On a passé un magnifique moment, Marie-Hélène et moi, à discuter de tous ces sujets.
J'espère que c'était le cas pour vous aussi.
Petit erratum puisque je sens qu'il y en a certainement plein parmi vous qui sont tombés en syncope quand j'ai dit que je n'étais pas né pendant les événements de l'affaire du Trou, la disparition de Julie et Mélissa.
Après vérification, si, je vous rassure, j'étais né, mais bon, j'avais deux ans, donc voilà, ça ne change pas grand-chose.
Un grand merci encore une fois à Marie-Hélène pour le temps qu'elle m'a accordé. J'espère que cette discussion a été aussi enrichissante pour vous que pour moi.
N'hésitez pas à aller visiter le blog de Marie-Hélène. Encore une fois, c'est Marie Accouche-là. Et comme elle l'a rappelé, elle a aussi publié un livre et ouvert une chaîne YouTube.
J'ai mis tous les liens en description. Quant à vous, si cet épisode vous a plu, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec, si ce n'est pas encore le cas.
C'est disponible sur toutes les plateformes et c'est gratuit. Et si vous avez l'occasion, n'oubliez pas de laisser un commentaire, une petite review cinq étoiles, ça fait toujours plaisir et ça aide beaucoup la croissance du podcast.
Un autre truc qui aide beaucoup d'ailleurs, puisque ce podcast est gratuit,
vous pouvez tout simplement en parler autour de vous puisqu'il y a certainement des personnes que ça peut intéresser, certainement des gens qui ont plein de choses à apprendre en écoutant Marie-Hélène parler des violences obstétricales.
Et sur ce, je vous dis à très bientôt. Portez-vous bien.